many of you are aware that the president
has asked me to
to focus on the issues of the root
causes of migration
um to the united states as you know we
inherited a tough situation
and um in five months we've made
progress but there's still much more
work to be done
that was kamala harris in el paso texas
yesterday making her
first visit as vice president to the
border let's bring in representative
kevin mccarthy house minority leader now
to react mr miro leader thank you so
much for being here so you can take on
what's your make on the location the
timing
and the message of the vice president
yesterday
well it seemed like she spent more time
at the airport than she spent at the
border
but to literally say that they inherited
a problem and they made progress
none of those facts play out you have a
border that was secure
you had a new administration that
changed executive
orders and invited people to rush the
border illegally
now in may we had a hundred and eighty
thousand encounters
that was a 21 year record of illegal
crossings
for the last three months it has
increased
the time that the president asked the
vice president to take on this job
half a million illegal individuals came
across
this border when counted those are the
only people we were able to encounter
think of there's going to be more than a
million individuals that get through
here that we don't encounter
from more than 160 countries and what's
worse pete you would understand this
we are catching people who are on the
terrorist watch list
from yemen well if it's open for
if it's open for some it's open for all
and and why if she's in charge of root
causes which is what she says how she
characterizes it
why go to el paso where most of the
illegal crossings are coming from mexico
as opposed to say mcallen
where you're seeing it from central
america i mean was any of this about
getting
to the truth of what's actually
happening no
we know why she's going because
president trump is going in a few days
she has denied the ability to even go
down there you know
she cackled and said she hasn't been to
europe either i wonder if next week is a
trip to europe yeah
but she needs to take this serious
there's so many ramifications one the
security and safety of this nation
it's never right to come here illegally
but fentanyl has now increased by 300
percent
and that's not just affecting border
cities every city in america is
now having people die from the fentanyl
that is being brought into this country
because of the border the cartels
that are overtaking these cities um this
is
this is a real threat to everyone in
america
and she's not taking it serious you know
by her denying going there
denying the facts of what's happening
and not going to the place that she
really
should be why only go to one place on
the border that border is very large
why spend an hour or two you know
absolutely
so many questions i got to get i get
your take on one other topic though
mr minority leader you know covet 19
showed how much of our scientific
community
is compromised by the the communist
chinese by global institutions
well now we've got another example from
corporate america
the nike ceo was talking to a series of
investors talking about the brand of
nike
here's this is what nike ceo john
donahue said just recently
we are the largest sport brand there
meeting in china and we are a brand
of china and for china and the biggest
asset we have in
china is consumer equity consumers feel
a strong deep connection
to the nike jordan and converse brands
in china
it's real of china for china last time i
checked nike was an american company
yeah you would think that i wonder if
google would say the same thing that's
right and think about what china has
just done to the world killed more than
three million people
killed more than 600 000 americans the
the country that china that nike was
created it
remember what china is a communist
country that you have to have a
communist representative
in every single business and remember
what china does too
they also have slave labor do you know i
put a bill on the floor recently
that said if any company manufactures in
china or contracts with somebody
manufacturing china
that uses slave labor they have to
report to the treasury
217 every single democrat voted no on
that
and denied that from coming forward but
we need to hold china accountable i just
rolled out eight pillars
we need to stop the gain of a gain of
function
first of all we need to get all of our
intel and declassify it so the world can
know where this kovid
came from in wu on next what we need to
do is
actually change the solver sovereign
unity the ability
for americans to hold them accountable
and sue for their loved ones
but why would the world reward china
with the winter olympics coming up
why wouldn't we move that and i would
think nike being a sports
outlet believing in the ability of
holding people accountable
wouldn't want to hold that in china but
now since they're a
company of china for china i would
question their ability to stand up to
them
yeah of course they have no problem with
it it's it's just amazing to me that an
entire political party in this country
appears to be completely unwilling to
take on the single greatest threat
to humanity which is the communist
chinese and their ambitions in the
coming century
thanks for standing up for it
representative kevin mccarthy really
appreciate your time this morning
thank you